you mind if I just bounce my ears off of
you sure you might know how to help me
sell the script I should report over the
look it's it's Oh as a narrative piece
and it's set all in North Korea from a
children's perspective inside a labor
camp who have to work as hackers but
it's a rom-com as a star you know maybe
like maddox Jolie Pitt
Tom Cruise's daughter you know she can't
be that expensive right now it's kind of
like a Schindler's List meets precious
kind of thing and emotional over John
Owen who's played by Jonah Hill but like
in like yellow face
okay this is trying to sort of piggyback
off the success of the interview except
I'm gonna have to change my passwords
they know they might even come after me
using the kids actually rise up and
they're trying to topple Kim jong-un and
what they actually find is that Kim
jong-un's not an evil guy he just wants
to learn how it's a beatbox this is like
internal dialogue of Maddox I looked
into his stone-cold eyes and I thought
this guy maybe he liked me
what do you think
alright doesn't interest me myself
ever take
is it hard you see kids in that
situation forget the kids they're adults
it could be like a superhero film
actually super film might be more
some movie wouldn't start it's so slow
well this is gonna be like you know
first scene kim jeong-hoon in a bathrobe
and it just drops how do you think I
should get to invest where do you think
I should hang out in order to meet these
people
so I just see how much Botox people have
in their face and we fly him down I
think that's the best way that's that's
me Francesca I just have like the first
two pages the rest I just filled in with
Good Will Hunting
I can get rid of I'll get rid of this
way give me your number I've hit the
water that by the script
yeah absolutely your luck just changed
when I walked in
you